we all know food is comfort and during
these
times i know we all need a little bit of
it i know i do
certainly local business grits cafe
says it will continue to feed the
community's soul through these times
sally jaramillo explains grace
it is a community based
restaurant we've been in business now
for 14 years
grits cafe says it's the ritz for the
grids
located near martha luther king and lake
mead boulevard
it offers southern familiarity to diners
we're all about economic empowerment so
when i first originally opened grits
cafe
my idea was to have a cafe where
people would come and do business and
they would feel like they were at home
in their mother's kitchen
trina giles owns grits cafe while trying
to stay afloat and adapt to changes
during a pandemic she also continues to
give back to the community
including first responders i believe
that it's important to make sure that we
provide
since we're being blessed with our loyal
customer base that we really do provide
some assistance to youth organizations
that's trying to make an
impact on our youth and bring them up in
a better life
despite closures and capacity reductions
she strives to bring loyal customers
quality cuisine
our number one seller is our chicken and
waffles
so southern fried chicken you can
accompany it with grits and our grits
you can top any way you'd like
from home style potatoes to chicken
fried steak catfish
biscuits and gravy you can find
everything that brings you that southern
comfort
food it can fix a lot of things when
it's the food is good that's why she's
feeding the valley
one grits bowl at a time her overall
message
to keep the faith stay positive there
are
a lot of opportunities out there she
encourages everyone to think outside the
box
keep growing and most importantly create
more jobs and opportunities for the
people in our community
i believe that all that i am i owe
to someone else who came before me sally
jaramillo 8 news now